que tu es crédible pour comprendre que
je suis sérieux tu penses que je l'ai fait
sans que tu dépenses un X dans cette guerre tu as
volé ça tu as trouvé parce que je me sens oh
ouais oh cool regarde faire un homme juste
garder la tête maintenant
tournez-vous
[Musique]
alors je vous ai parlé de mon frère mais
quelque chose s'est passé Je ne sais pas exactement
ce qui vient d'être arrêté à
Rikers Island oh mon dieu c'est génial,
je dois juste leur donner un pourboire ou
quelque chose de dur à cuire dans lequel vous vous faites tuer  cette
[ __ ] d'autre subvention de bronzage vous obtenez
encore 10000 votre bouteille sortez la vérité
[Musique]
Je pense que quelque chose de très important se
passe et profondément lié à mon
but chaque jour je pense à
tordre Londres en faisant tinter ces cordes dans lesquelles
je suis pour diriger un  Pure Life
[Musique]
regarde devant et le ciel clair n'y arrivera
pas c'est un beau rêve c'est un bel arbre
[Musique]
toi